[Music]
and a few wool I mean it's gotta be
surreal for you it's been such a huge
part of your life it is it is odd man
whenever you know and now at this point
it's just kind of like second nature I
get it now I've sat with it for over a
year but whenever I get really deep into
thinking in the past you know really
nostalgic it really hits me I can't
really never get really emotional I was
there every step of the way I love that
thing like a plague a loved one I love
that show like a person there it's an
extension of me and I will always love
it and miss it back you get a chance to
steal anything from set I haven't yet
but my plan is to get a lacrosse stick
and Scott's a motorcycle you start off
as Jennifer Lopez kid and made Manhattan
I mean what would you tell that little
guy knowing what you know now and
standing where you are where you go man
I'm gonna motional keep doing what
you're doing man keep your eyes open
because there's a lot of things you
don't want to miss I like where I've
come man and where I am and just keep
doing what you're doing buddy and one
day you're gonna be covered in tattoos
yeah
[Music]